again from princeton giving the second
lecture in his course
on the discrete queue all right
um thank you nike so um
basically uh i still owe you something
from the last lecture
so um let's see i just copied some of
the things that i had in the last
lecture
um so remember that last time
we uh proved the punch inequality the
poker inequality just says that the
variance of any function on the discrete
cube is bounded by the expectation of
the square of its discrete gradient
and the beauty of this equation which i
emphasize again is that
the constant okay the constant being one
is not so important
but the constant doesn't depend on
dimension right which means this is this
is really a high dimensional phenomenon
and if any function
in arbitrary dimension that is
sufficiently smooth will have
fluctuations of the same order the
fluctuations do not grow if they mention
and this is really why such inequalities
are important in many different areas
um so how did we do this in order to
prove it we introduced this object
that's called the semi group ptf so to
any function f on the discrete cubes it
associates a function pt of f
and uh what this what this semi group
does is it interpolates between the
function itself and its expectation
right so a t is zero it gives a function
that t is infinity it gives the
expectation
and this is the way that we control the
variance the variance is the
expectation of f squared minus the
expectation of f squared so by
interpolating between these things we
were able to bound the difference so i
explained
this last time so exactly how we came to
this doesn't matter for this lecture
at the end of the day here we have a
very explicit description of what this
pt
is right ptf of epsilon the function ptf
of epsilon is just the expectation of
the function f
of epsilon times c and c are these
biased
bernoulli variables right they take the
values plus or minus one with
probability one plus or minus e to the
minus t over two
and once you have that we can take that
as a definition if you want
then we just started computing and i
needed a list of um
of properties which i have reproduced
here in this lemma and i promised you
that i would prove them
so let's do it um
so the first property is that if i take
the expectation of ptf that's just the
expectation of if right so the semigroup
doesn't change the expectation
well let's just compute it what's the
expectation of pt of if
well if you look at this formula right
and you see in the formula for ptf
epsilon was fixed and c was random
so now if we take the expectation we're
just taking the expectation with respect
to
epsilon right so this is just the
expectation over c and epsilon
of the function of epsilon c t right so
here epsilon are iid random bits
probability plus or minus one being
one-half and ct is this
biased version of it right but now if we
average over epsilon you see
i can take the expectation with respect
to epsilon first
right so even though these cts think of
the cts being fixed these are just a
bunch of signs
right if i have bernoullis with
probability one half of being plus or
minus one
if i multiply this by a sign by any sign
it's still going to be plus or minus one
with probability one one-half
right so as soon as i take the
expectation with respect to epsilon
the c completely disappears from the
story right so this is just equal to the
expectation of f of epsilon which is the
expectation of
of f in my notation so
this is a very uh it's a trick that we
will use later very um
crucially um if you take the expectation
with respect to unbiased bernoullis it
doesn't matter what you multiply them
you can multiply them by any random
variables of any sign as long as they're
independent of the epsilon they're not
going to change the distribution
so it's a simple observation but here
you have it
now um the second uh point
we had to compute how the rate of change
of the semi group over time right this
was the key point in the computation of
the
of the bunker inequality so let's just
compute what ptf is
okay so what is ptf of epsilon well i
wrote up here in fact where you see fact
i have an expression it's the
expectation with respect to some random
variable so i can just write
out the formula for what that
expectation is because i told you what
are the probabilities of these random
variables right so this is the sum
over all vectors c in minus 1 plus 1 to
the n
and now i can just write out the
probability that c i is equal to c1 is
equal to
little c1 c2 of t is equal to c of t xc2
etc alright so this is the product j
is 1 to n of 1
plus c j e to the minus t over two right
so this is the probability
one of these terms the j term is just
the probability that c j of t
is equal to the sine c j right
times the function of epsilon times x
and so i've just written out the
explicit distribution of this
of these random variables and now you
notice we can play the same game as in
part zero right because um here i
sum over all strings c of plus or minus
one to the n
right so if i multiply them by any signs
i can just sum them in a different order
right so if i i can i can multiply here
c by any random sign
epsilon and it doesn't change because
i'm just summing over
all possible strings of links n right so
i can equivalently write this as the sum
of
c in plus or minus 1 to the n
of the product j is 1 to n but i can
multiply every cj by epsilon j
it doesn't matter because i'm summing
over all possibilities of cj anyway
right it's just a change of variables
so i can write this as 1 plus epsilon j
x c j
e to the minus t over 2. uh and now we
just get f of x
i haven't changed anything i've done
this change of variables
well now you can just compute so what
happens if i take d dt
of ptf epsilon right so t only appears
inside this product so it's a product of
n terms so i have to do the product rule
right so it's um sum
i is 1 to n and now in the i
term i took the derivative of the i
object over here right so i get epsilon
i
c i e to the minus t over 2
and i should get a minus because i
differentiate e to the minus t
and then the remaining terms are the js
are not equal to i
one plus epsilon j c j e to the minus t
over two
times f of c right so i just applied the
product rule
but now if you look at each term in the
sum that's exactly what i would get
if i took the epsilon i right if i
flipped the sign of the epsilon i and i
subtracted it
from this object over here right in the
i term the one
plus would drop out and i'd get exactly
the same term right so this is nothing
else than minus some i
is one to n of d i
of ptf all right do you just see it from
the formula
right when i took d dt then in the i
term the one plus disappeared because it
was constant i just got minus e to the
minus t
but that's the same as saying okay what
happens if i flip the i
bit the epsilon well
then i just change the the term of the e
to the minus t right
the one also drops out and i get exactly
the same so this is again just a
computation you can just once you have a
formula you can just compute all these
things by hand
right and the laplacian is that i denote
by delta is minus the sum of the i right
that's the definition of the laplace
good now in part two i just did some
linear algebra
you see yes please uh
maybe one question is the missing sum on
psi oh that's very possible absolutely
um let me stick it in
thank you very much
you can of course not just stop summing
there we go and the second question
is more philosophical okay i mean it's
so
the expressions here that looks a little
bit like fourier
fourier expression so somebody's asking
if it's
obvious or dumb but is that rewriting
after change of fiber some sort of
fourier expansion since you promised not
to do free expansion i guess
so you know the laplacian has the
fourier the the the
average functions as this eigenfunction
so everything i write out
i mean almost by definition can be
written in terms of free expansion
but um uh you know another way to say it
is that if you look at this formula i
have for ptf
you see this is just a convolution if
you write this in fourier language i've
just written here the convolution of
f with this function over here this heat
kernel over here
so it's not surprising that if i have a
convolution on the discrete cube when i
fourier transform it just turns into a
product right that's the explanation why
um this pt will become diagonal on the
fourier basis
so i want to emphasize that nothing i
have done in this first lecture and by
extension here
really benefits from having the
perspective of these random variables
that they introduced
absolutely nothing in this lemma that i
wrote over here
basically everything can be proved in in
in two lines using fourier expansion if
i had started with free expansion many
of these things would be obvious but i
wouldn't even have had to do them
because
the poincare inequality is obvious from
the fourier perspective itself
um you're not going to see the payoff of
thinking about this in this way
until um until we prove something new
okay so right now
um even though i wrote just to set up
the language notation i'm going to use
in all the lectures i wrote everything
in terms of these random variables
ct and i'm being very pedantic about it
right
but right now you cannot see what the
payoff of this is you will see what the
payoff of this is when we prove new
things
and and in those new things we don't
know how to or at least i don't know how
to express that in fourier
okay so but it is true those of you who
you who know
fourier expansions not only can but
should
feel that i'm doing a lot of very
pedantic things that that could have
been done much easier
okay but going back to the drawing board
is
is is good because it will lead us to
think about the problems in a different
way
okay not to die not that even this is
anything new what i'm writing here but
but
uh but you will see this maybe not in
this lecture but at the very beginning
of the next lecture we will see why
um why this paid off okay i hope this
answered the question
um let's talk about part two part two
should be
uh more or less obvious from part one um
so except for what is the notation mean
you know these are functions on the
discrete cube the disc cube is a finite
set
right so you should just think of these
functions as big vectors two to the
n-dimensional vectors
and then this object called ptf which is
just a linear function of f
you can just think of it as a big matrix
right and similarly the laplacian you
can just think of it as a matrix
so all of these formulas when i just i
can view them as matrix vector formulas
right so when i write ddt
ptf equals laplacian ptf if you think of
pt as a matrix and f of a vector
right you could just drop f of both
sides you have d d t p t as laplacian p
t
obviously the solution of that equation
is p t is e to the t times laplace
right and from this you can see
immediately for example that all of the
derivatives commute with pt and the
derivatives commute with the laplacian
because the laplacian is just the sum of
derivatives and the
derivatives commute with each other okay
so it's just a shorthand way of of of
seeing a lot of simple formulas that
that we could also check by hand if you
want let's
uh let's do part three so this is again
this is integration by parts but
integration by parts on the discrete
cube is not exactly rocket science right
so
what is the expectation of f times the
laplacian of g
right by definition of the laplacian
this is minus the sum
of expectation of f times d i
g right and now
you should remember that that's so maybe
let me put in the epsilons
you should remember that uh one of the
very first things that i remarked about
these discrete derivatives is that d
i is antisymmetric
um d i is anti-symmetric
in epsilon i if i flip the sine of
epsilon i then the i derivative will
flip sine
okay this is because i can write d i
f of epsilon as epsilon i times partial
i
f of epsilon where partial i is this
derivative where i just set the alphabet
to my
one minus where i set the i to minus one
and i divide by two
right so this partial i doesn't depend
on epsilon i
so you see that d i is just linear in
epsilon i and therefore
if i flip the sine of epsilon i i just
flip the sine of d i
so what does this mean this means that
the expectation of f epsilon d i g of
epsilon
if i flip the sign of the i bit of
course nothing changes because
the i take the expectation right the
eighth bit is plus or minus one was
probably one half
so if i flip the sign of the ice bit the
expectation remains the same
right but if i flip the sign of the i
bit
right then the first term will become
have the sign of the i-bit flipped
but by anti-symmetry d i g of epsilon
will just become minus d i g of epsilon
right so i just get plus
d i g of epsilon
right so i have here two formulas for
laplacian the first one and the second
one
this one has a minus the second one
doesn't have a minus
right and the second one only has the i
bit flipped and if
right but if i average these two
formulas which are the same
then i get exactly what i claimed i get
right because f of epsilon
minus f where i flip the i bit divided
by two that's exactly the definition of
the discrete derivative
right so all i've done here in some
sense is integrated by both
okay so this goes a bit quickly but you
know you can check it for yourself
and the fourth one is maybe the most
interesting one so let's again use this
property
so let's compute what is d i p t
if of epsilon
well by part 2 i can exchange d i and p
t so i can write this as p
t d i f of epsilon right
because the semi group and the
derivative commute
and now let's write out
probabilistically what this means right
so this is the expectation
c of what of d
i f of epsilon c t right this is using
the representation for the semi group
and now let's use this property so let's
write this
in terms of this one-sided derivative
times epsilon i right but here
the thing is not a function of epsilon
it's a function of epsilon c t
right so i can write this as epsilon i i
don't take the exponential with respect
to epsilon
times the expectation of ct
times partial i
f of epsilon ct so here i'm using the
anti-symmetry if you want of the
discrete derivative
but you see this partial i by definition
doesn't depend on ct
uh robot sorry i think uh
maybe no someone commented the writing
is a bit small so people are having
trouble reading it i think
oh it's too small yeah i'm i'm reaching
the end of the page and i'm uh um
getting smaller and smaller
unfortunately i have no idea how to
zoom in this object that i have here
this this ipad
i think also you we cannot see the
bottom bottom of your screen so before
people is this okay
yeah that's better but um should i
rewrite it bigger
i think scrolling up helped actually
okay so let's uh let's continue then as
it
is um so where are we at we have the
expectation of ct times partial i f
epsilon c t
but this thing doesn't depend on the i
coordinate right
so i can just these two these i can just
take the expectation with respect to c
sorry this should be c i of t of course
i can just take the expectation of x c i
of t
and that's e to the minus t right so
this is epsilon i
e to the minus t times the expectation
of this partial i but that's just p t
of this partial i of f
this is an identity now if i square both
sides the epsilon will disappear
the e to the minus t will turn e to the
minus 2t which i had over here
and then i can just apply jensen p t of
partial i f is less or equal than
p t squared is less or equal pt of
partial i f squared
and because partial i f only differs by
a sign from dif that's the expectation
of the af squared and i get exactly this
so again there's nothing deep going on
here this is just a you know once you
have this probabilistic representation
um you can just do these computations
manually
and uh and you will see that um all of
these properties simply pop
up okay so um this is probably
yes there's one more question about just
the definition of the laplacian
yes why i mean
why do you have the minus sign ah
um this is a convention even if when the
with the regular laplacian
there is a um
there are different conventions for what
sign you put on them um
so i for example think of the regular
laplacian as the sum
of the second derivative squared but an
analyst would think about it with a
minus
so this laplacian is negative
semi-definite
and you can see it here right this e to
the t times laplacian this is the semi
group
this had better be a contraction
otherwise it could not be a probability
uh it could not be a probability right
so this this laplacian has to have
non-positive eigenvalues
right the way i defined it here of
course i could have removed the minus
but then i would have to put a minus
everywhere else where the laplacian
appears
so this is just a convention what do you
call the convention but i've chosen the
same convention that you would use
if you call the regular laplacian nrn
the sum of the second derivatives of the
function
okay so that's i'm using that convention
for a little plus
but if you don't like it you can remove
the minus and then put a minus
everywhere else where i wrote the
laplacian and it would still be correct
so this is good are there other
questions
you will find both conventions used i
think equally in the literature so it
just depends on
on what type of person you're talking to
okay it is my aim and
you can tell me if i'm successful at the
end that this what i just did is the
most boring part of the four talks
okay so you can
you can tell me if i succeed okay all
right
let's move on to something else ah no i
want to make one more comment before i
move on
let's make a remark
so remember the poincare inequality says
that the variance
is bounded by the expectation of the
discrete derivative
squared let's treat the world's
stupidest example
let's take a linear function
okay just a linear combination of the
signs right with some coefficients a i
right so what is the variance of this
the mean is zero
right because i just took a linear
combination of sine so the variance is
just the expectation of the squared
and of course you know you could just
expand the square the expectation of
epsilon i squared is one the expectation
of epsilon
i epsilon j is zero so this is just the
sum i is one to n of a i squared
but actually d i of f if i take what
happens if i take
the the ith derivative right so i take
the function of epsilon
minus the function where i flip the sign
only of the if bit and i divide by two
of course that's just a i right
so this is equal to the expectation of
the gradient of the function squared
so actually you see this constant one is
sharp in the punch inequality linear
functions
they achieve the equality case of the
punch are inequality
so it's good to think about linear
functions i'm not just making this
remark uh
um for the heck of it in a moment i'm
going to come back to this rule
okay so um but for now just view this as
one
very very simple example all right
so now um now we're ready to go on and
actually
uh do something new and what i'm going
to do is the rest of this lecture i'm
mostly going to
ask the right questions and the real
punch line of these lectures will come
at the very beginning of the next
lecture at least that's my plan
okay so um let's ask some questions that
are not completely classical
so the questions i'm going to ask about
are about
vector-valued functions
so remember the punch inequality is an
equality for real valued functions
right but what happens if i take a
function from the discrete cube
that takes values in some norm space
right so it's some vector space
and i'll put a norm on it okay
and then you could ask a very basic
question right these types of
inequalities like the one i've just
shown you
do they make sense for vector valued
functions right
are there
vector valued
of the poncarena quote
and if you think about this question i'm
going to show you some examples a little
bit later on which will motivate maybe a
little bit more why you should care
about those things
um but um if you're interested for
example in in functional analysis this
is a very natural question in its own
right right is there a vector-valued
analog of the punch array inequality
and if you start thinking just about
this question the way i phrased it
um it's not even clear what it means
right you know
if if we want to have a vector value
inequality we'd better write down
something that even makes sense
all right so let's try to um let's try
to imagine
uh what what what it could look like
right
so here's the first attempt
okay so let me remind you that what is
the scalar punch inequality it says the
variance is bounded
by the sum of the derivatives squared
right so let me just write the scalar
inequality again
it says that the variance well you can
write the variance as the expectation
of f minus expectation squared
right is bounded by sum i is 1 to n
of the expectation of the derivative of
the functions
right this this this is just a puncher
inequality for scalar functions written
out again
so now of course this inequality doesn't
make any sense if f takes values in a
vector space because you can't square a
vector
right now f of epsilon is a vector right
you can't square a vector
but this space has a norm on it and let
me just to to distinguish it from the
euclidean norm let me call that norm x
the norm in this vector space
right well well the most natural thing
that you could do is that f is a vector
i could just
turn each of these guys into a norm
and now the inequality makes perfect
sense let me add in a constant just so
you don't think that i'm too pedantic
okay so here i wrote an equality i just
wrote down the poincare inequality again
for scalar functions with every phrase i
saw an absolute value i just turned into
a norm
now i have an inequality which makes
perfect sense
for vector-valued functions right and
now you can ask yourself whether this
inequality makes sense
so let's see what the problem is
now remember i just did a very silly
example in the linear
in in the in the scalar case i plugged
in the linear function
right and then we saw that that was
great because for linear functions the
poincare inequality was even equality
so let's try to do this now right
because in the vector valued case
because linear functions make sense in
any vector space right so let's pick a
linear function
sum i is 1 to n epsilon i
x i now the coefficients are not numbers
but the coefficients are just some
vectors
right so this is a linear this function
is linear in the epsilon just a linear
combination of some given vectors
right so let me give this inequality let
me call it star
right so suppose we plug the linear
function into star what would it give
well on the left hand side we'd have
that the expectation
of the norm of this linear combination
of vectors with random signs
right and
on the right hand side we have some i
is 1 to n remember d i of
f is just x i so we just get
um the norm of x i
squared in this space so if this
inequality star were true
then you should also have this
inequality for a linear function in
particular which is a very special kind
of function
right you should have this statement
that the expectation of the norm of a
linear combination of vectors with
random signs
squared should be bounded by the sum of
the squares of the norms of those
vectors
well so what doesn't look so bad but the
point is that there is no reason for
such inequalities to be true
right so for example this is true
if x is a hilbert space
or euclidean norm
if you want to think about finite
dimensional vectors with the euclidean
norm
right because for euclidean or if x is
the opposite space the norm is just the
sum of the squares of the individual
elements right
so then of course this inequality just
follows from the scalar case immediately
but for example what happens if
x is l1 right so this is another
perfectly fine norm the l1 norm so let's
check it
and let's take x i to be the coordinate
vectors
right so x i are going to be the vectors
um
that have i that have a zero
can you lift the screen a little bit yes
that have a one in the i coordinates and
the zero everywhere else these are these
are just going to be the coordinate
vectors
right and so then the sum i is 1 to n
of epsilon i x i is just going to be the
vector
of epsilon 1 through epsilon n right so
it's a vector of random signs
so if i took the l1 norm of a vector of
random signs the sum of the absolute
values that's just
n right so on the left hand side we have
n squared because we have a square here
on this norm right
but each of the x i's which is a vector
which just has one one in it the norm of
that is just one
so on the right hand side we have a sum
of n ones which is n right
so if x were the l1 norm then on the
left hand side we have n squared and on
the right hand side we have n
and then obviously this inequality
cannot hold with a dimension free
constant
so you see that even though in the
scalar case there was one poincare
inequality it was very clear what it
should be
in the vector case you know it's not at
all clear that such a thing would be
true it depends on the properties of the
of the norm x so
in some sense it seems that this is not
the right question to ask um
because even in the linear case we don't
understand what is the right thing right
in the linear case the behavior of
linear functions depends very strongly
on what the norm is that you choose in
the space
right so if the behavior of linear
functions even depends very strongly on
what the norm is that you're choosing in
your space how can you hope to
understand non-linear functions right i
mean this is uh
it should depend on you know i mean for
different norms you can get
completely different behavior right so
um my point with this example is mostly
to try to
indicate that
it's not even clear how you should
formulate such a property right i mean
it seems that the formulation should
depend on
what norm what norm you have on x right
because
even if we look at the simplest possible
example it's not possible to write down
exactly what happened right the behavior
of linear functions on an arbitrary
bonus space
can behave in all sorts of different
ways right there's there's no one way
that such things behave
um in fact you know that problem itself
is one of them you know extremely deep
problems in probability theory there
were going to be
lectures about this by james lee but i
saw that the program changed so um
um you need some techniques called
generic chaining in order to
to to study them in complete generality
and it can get almost arbitrarily
complicated right
and that's linear functions and i'm
asking you to give an inequality for
nonlinear functions
right so um
how should we formulate such so
um what i want to talk about is that
um there is a way to formulate this
this question um and uh
let me give it a name i just made it up
so i want to talk about
something let's call it a linear to
non-linear principle
okay and informally what does this
linear
to non-linear principle say it says that
the
behavior of nonlinear functions
on the norm's face
should be determined by the behavior of
the linear functions
let's say controlled
by the behavior
of the linear functions so what do i
mean by this
um you know indifference
when you have different norms right if
you have different boundary spaces
linear functions behave in very very
different ways right i cannot write down
one theorem that explains to you
how linear functions behave in the norm
space well you can it's called the the
bernoulli problem but
this is you know it doesn't tell you
much in this context right
so we have to admit the fact that
you know the behavior of linear
functions depends very strongly on on on
what norm you put on i'm not going to be
able to write down one theorem that
explains it
right but what i want to say is i want
to prove a theorem for nonlinear
functions that says that okay no matter
what the
how the linear functions behave if you
tell me how the linear functions behave
then i can give you an inequality for
non-linear functions that reflects that
behavior
right so the nonlinear functions no
matter how the linear function behave i
should be able to write down
a sort of concave inequality that says
that the linear function the nonlinear
functions behave in such a way
that it reproduces the correct behavior
of the linear functions okay
so this is a very vague statement and i
want to convince you that the statement
makes sense
and um and that it uh
that we can prove it and that it has
interesting uh implications etc
okay so this is where i want to go um so
before i try to discover a general
statement you know how do you state this
principle mathematically
um let me give an example right so
of something that would capture this but
only in a special case okay so and
this example i'm giving it um
because this is what was originally
conjectured so this this is historically
uh
where these type of questions actually
come from um
so let me make a definition
so a norm space
is said to have type
p
if the expectation of linear functions
of the norm of a linear function
on this space behaves like this
so in the scalar case or in a hilbert
space we know that this is true of p
equals 2
and that's exactly what's captured by
the regular poincare inequality
but in the general bond of space there's
no reason why this should be true or
equal to for example we saw that for the
l1 norm
this inequality is absolutely not true
if p equals two right
so let's try to replace the power two by
a power p right
now that still doesn't say anything this
is just the property of a certain norm
space
right so you you could view this type
this is just a definition the norm space
has
property of type having type p if you
have this type of parallelogram identity
but with a power p
in it right so for example
if we look at the spaces lp
or the sequence space is lp they have
type p
if p is between one and two
and they have type two
if p is between two and infinity
okay so now you can see you know that
that that's
that uh this is just an example but you
can see that that different norm spaces
have different type right it's just a
property you can view this as a property
of the number right
now if we believe in this linear
non-linear principle then we would guess
that okay
well i cannot write a general statement
because it's not all like all norm
spaces have the same type but if i give
you a space of type e
then i should have a poincare inequality
that behaves like this
right so then one has the following
statement right if
x has type p
then the expected norm of f minus the
expectation of f
squared now to the p is bounded by some
i is one to n
of the expectation sorry yes no of the
expectation of d
i f to the power p all right so it's
just like a poncho inequality but i now
replaced
p 2 by p right
and for example if you plug in a linear
function to this inequality you get just
the definition of type p back
so different space is a different type
but no but whatever
property the linear functions have
should be reflected in the in in the
poincare inequality
so this is an example it's not a more
general statement but because this
definition of type e
is one particular type of inequality you
could have for linear functions of the
norm space
um but this example certainly reflects
this idea behind this linear to
non-linear principle right the poincare
inequality which says something about
nonlinear functions
should always be such that it reflects
the behavior of the linear functions
right and
and this inequality if it's true by
definition is stating that the space is
has type p just by plugging in linear
functions
yes yes mark you want to mention the
range of people which the type is
relevant yes mark makes a very good
point
spaces can only have type p if p
is between 1 and 2.
every space has type one because that
that inequality has a very good name
this is called the triangle inequality
okay so if you have p is one then i've
just written here the triangle
inequality so every space is type one
and in that case we say that this place
has trivial type okay because the
triangle inequality is not exactly
interesting property
um and in that case the poincare
inequality is also trivial because it
just falls from the triangle
you can just flip the bits one by one
type two
is um type two is hilbert base and you
cannot have more than type two why can't
you have more than type two
because in every linear space you can
just take a one-dimensional subspace
and it behaves like the scalar case and
the scalar case has type two
so you can never do better than that yes
there's another question
yeah it was just should the type
constant also be in the theorem
or there is a constant c which of course
uh depends on
x okay this is the type p constant of
the space x
um i don't want to get bogged down on
these things because
i i just using this as an example of a
more general statement that has nothing
to do with type
okay so um if you're interested in bonus
space theory then
this is where the question came from it
was conjectured by
um by pair and flow
and flow in
uh in the 60s 70s
formerly 1987 and we proved it in uh
recently with uh
ramon i think the question was the
constant should be in the last line of
the statement of the theory oh sorry let
me put a constant here and this constant
should be
uh connected to the constant here in the
uh
in in the definition of type of course
right um
i think we get it it's the constant
definition of type times uh
square root pi over two or something pi
over square root i don't remember
exactly but something like that
thanks thanks for all these corrections
um but again i don't want to
um um
i don't want to emphasize this notion of
type too much because actually you know
this is just one example right this is
just
one way of expressing how linear
functions might behave on a boundary
space
right but there are many other
interesting ways of expressing how
linear functions behave in a bonus page
you can have much better inequalities
than this or different
than the qualities that look very
different right so this is just
i mean if you want to understand what i
mean by linear to non-linear principle
um this is just one example you know
here is some way of expressing how
linear functions behave
right and i want to say that if you have
such an inequality for linear functions
there should follow a non-linear
inequality for arbitrary nonlinear
functions
that reflects that behavior of the
linear function right
um but um so so so if you
take this definition as how you want to
express how linear functions behave
then this then it's clear that this
should be the right punch inequality
right but it's not at all clear why that
inequality should be true
right and and and that is what we're
going to try to discover
okay so for us this is just an example
um
but we don't want just this example we
actually want to say something much more
general we would like to
um say something much more general about
this linear to non-linear principle
we would like to understand why is it
that non-linear functions behave in a
way that i only have to know how linear
functions behave and i could say
something about nonlinear functions
i mean this seems completely ridiculous
right i mean linear functions are very
special type of functions how come
i can um make an assumption about how
linear functions behave and then say
okay all nonlinear functions behave
you know at least like that right so we
have to understand why you have such a
linear non-linear principle and that's
going to be our goal
okay so um that's the aim
um by the way the origin of this end
flow problem
uh you know it actually has uh various
very interesting applications
um and it has to do with embeddings what
you can embed in bonus spaces whether
you can embed metric spaces in bonus
spaces and things like this so i'm not
going to talk about that
um but it is actually a if you're a
functional analyst and or your isometric
geometry this is a very basic
type of question that you would want to
ask all right um
good so uh let's move beyond this so
this is just an example
um but what we would really like is a
more general statement right so i would
like to understand this more general
statement and again we're back in the
same situation as we were before
it's not even clear what to write them
okay so what i want to do for the rest
of this lecture is talk about
um an easier case
which is the case uh in the gaussian
world right so up to now we've been
talking about the discrete cube
but as uh anyone who has worked with the
discrete cube
uh knows that uh often it's easier to
to have analogous inequalities for
gaussian random variables
and if you understand the gaussian case
first that's no promise that you
understand the discrete cube
but um it is uh certainly a nice step
towards understanding any problem
and in the gaussian case it turns out
that this linear to non-linear principle
is understood completely in a very
general set
okay and i want and that gives us uh
once we understand that
that also directs us to what we would
like to prove because you know then we
have some sort of idea about how to
mathematically state this linear to
non-linear
okay so um let me
um is there another question or shall i
move on
uh herman yeah uh so i was just curious
it's
probably not related to the subject that
you're going to pursue but i was
wondering if there is a version of the
strong von korean quality for covariance
matrices if one can
um maybe i'll answer it later i'm not
sure but but let's let's uh
i'm going to give an example that's
related to that i'm not sure what strong
covariance in quality for procurement
let me get back to this question and you
can ask me at the end
is that okay yeah sure sure okay thanks
kalina so um
uh let me write down a a theorem in the
gaussian case okay so now
imagine let's forget for a moment about
the discrete cube and let's imagine that
we have gaussian instead of iid random
signs we have iid gaussian render
variables
okay standard gaussian random variables
now of course punch inequality makes
perfect sense as well you just get that
the variance of a function f is bounded
by the expected gradient squared the
norm of the gradient squared
and now we would like to know something
about vector value function
and in this setting there is a very
beautiful theorem
um which
was proved by gpca let's call this
pcas gaussian
linear to non-linear principle
which explains in a completely general
setting why this is true that the
behavior
of linear functions gives you
inequalities for nonlinear
okay so um it's in the gaussian case but
it's
but it works in any norm space it's
completely general in that sense
um how is it stated
let's take g
be a standard gaussian vector so this
this is going to take the
this is a standard gaussian vector of
mean zero and unit covariance matrix
um and uh this is going to replace my
epsilons my random signs right so this
is what we're going to plug into our
function
but we're also going to take another
vector independent copy g
prime so g prime is just another
standard gaussian vector that's
independent of g
okay then
for every function now we're gaussian so
we live on rn
into a norm space x
okay what do we have we have that the
expectation
of the norm of f minus the expectation
of f
to the p let's take any p
expectation of f minus h of f to the
power p
is bounded by some constant actually the
constant is pi over 2 to the
there p go times the expectation
of the norm of sum i is one to n
g i prime times the derivative of f in
the direction i
and that is pci's inequality and so
you see rather than having something
like the sum of the squares
of the norms of the derivatives on the
right hand side or the sum of the p
power of the norms of derivative to the
right hand side right these things
you know these things depend on the bond
of space what is the right right
statement so this p
is not the p that comes from having type
p this inequality is true for any p
right what i'm saying here is that on
the right hand side what you should take
is you should take a linear combination
of the derivative
whose coefficients themselves are
independent gaussians
right so this here is a linear function
right
if we fix g
this is a linear function
of this gaussian vector g prime right
so you see whatever the behavior is of
linear functions under this norm x we
can just condition on g on the right
hand side
apply the linear inequality to this
linear combination of the derivatives
and then we get that the same behavior
is inherited by the
by by the nonlinear functions if right
so for example
right if x
has what is called gaussian type p
okay so that means that the expectation
of the norm sum i is 1 to n
epsilon i x i to the p is bounded by
some i's one to n of the norms
right so this is exactly the same sorry
gi now i want gi
so it's exactly the same as the
definition of type but rather than
taking a linear combination of random
signs i take a linear combination with
gaussians
actually it turns out that this
definition gaussian type e is equivalent
to the definition of of type b but i
don't want to get into that right now
um so this is just statement about the
behavior of linear functions but in the
gaussian case
well we can just apply this linear
inequality to the right hand side over
here in pca's inequality
right we just condition on g and we just
apply this with the linear function
being as a function of g
prime right then
we get that for any nonlinear function
the expectation of f minus expectation
of f to the p is bounded by this const
by some constant so there's going to be
some constant
right times sum i
is 1 to n of df dxi
x to the p which is just like the
gaussian form of the inflow conjecture
so you see this this this this notion of
type is just one way that you can
express how linear functions behave in
the boundary space
but this this inequality of pci explains
for any bonus space
what is the relation between the
properties of linear functions and
between the properties of nonlinear
functions right because it says that
the expectation of the norm of a
function minus x any non-linear function
by its expectation
is bounded by the expectation of a
linear function
right the linear function so a sum with
gaussian coefficients a linear function
but where the vectors of the linear
function are exactly the derivatives of
the nonlinear function
because g and g prime are independent i
can now apply any statements about
linear functions on the right hand side
and get a corresponding inequality for
nonlinear functions
and i think this inequality is one you
know there's
a lot of literature on functional this
is one that you don't see all that often
phrased
particularly in this vector-valued case
and it's a very powerful principle and
you can apply this to all sorts of other
situations let me give you another
sort of example maybe to um satisfy
galena
let's talk about matrices okay so just
as another example so let's take
let's a1 to
am be some t by d let's say symmetric
matrix
just for
for simplicity right and now we would
like to understand
um there is a there is a very classical
fact which is called the non-commutative
kitchen inequality
let me just write it like this so
non-commutative kitchen inequality which
says that if i take the expectation of
the norm
of some linear combination of these
matrices with gaussian coefficients
let's say let's take for example the
operator norm
this is actually a consequence of the
non-communication equality
it's i think it was first noticed by
mark wilson this is bounded by square
root log of the dimension
times what the sum of the matrices
squared
operator norm square root okay so this
is a result in random matrix theory it
says that if you have a random matrix
with gaussian entries not necessarily
independent but then here is a result in
random matrix theory that tells you
how to compute or how to estimate the
norm of that random matrix the largest
eigenvalue of that random matrix okay
and you see if we view it from our
perspective we think of these d by d
matrices as being vectors in our vector
space
and the coefficients gi are so this is
just a linear function
of matrices right now suppose that we
want a nonlinear version of this what do
we do now let's consider
a function from rn to d by d
symmetric matrices so this is now a
non-linear function
right so what does pca's inequality
tells us tell us it says that if i take
this
matrix-valued function i subtract the
mean i take the operator norm
well pca's inequality tells us that this
is bounded by pi over 2
times the expectation of sum i is 1 to n
gi prime times the the
derivative sorry i'm not in the vector
in the
cube yet times the derivative of this
function which is of course still a
matrix because it's a matrix-valued
function
in the i-coordinate but now i can just
condition on g and apply the
non-commutative kitchen inequality to
this linear combination of matrices each
matrix is the derivative of the function
f
with respect to a different value right
and then i get that this is bounded by
square root log d
times the expectation of the sum
i is 1 to n of the derivative
squared
with a square root and remember that f
is a matrix-valued function so df dxi is
also a matrix-valued function so
when i write square here this is just
the square of the matrix as a matrix
right um so here i have a completely
non-trivial quad you know i started with
a non-trivial inequality about
random matrices of a you know
which are linear right which i have
gaussian entries
and i for free turn this into an
inequality for a much much much more
general model of random matrices
where i can take any matrix-valued
function of a gaussian vector
that's an extremely general model of
random matrices and i have obtained here
for free
an inequality about the norms of these
non-linear matrices
right that depend nonlinearly on
gaussian variables just because i knew
something about
matrices with gaussian entries so
it's just one more example right of this
linear to non-linear principle
um but it shows how powerful this this
uh
you know the statement of pca is because
it says something about any vector space
and you know why talk about matrices you
know you can invent any favorite object
that you have that lives in the linear
space
um you know it's the simon's from
salmon's institute you know
every time that uh if you uh
my experience is if you talk to people
machine learning they all perk up
magically if you say the word tensor
okay so um so let's take tensor right
you know so
uh uh tensors well you can add them up
right
so therefore they live in the linear
space and
now you can try to write down some norm
for example some sort of maximum of the
tensor or something whatever you care
about
may be a hard problem to uh find norms
of tensors right to bound the norm of a
gaussian tensor let's say but if you
have any inequality the bounds of normal
gaussian tensor then
boom stick it into pca inequality now
you for free have an inequality for a
very much much more general model of
random things
right so um i hope you're properly
impressed by the power of this
inequality right and this is a very
general principle which is this linear
to non-linear principle
and and we have it in the gaussian case
and so now we know what we aspired
all right this is what we aspire to
achieve but we would like to achieve it
on the discrete cube
i see that somebody raised their hand
there's also some a question in the chat
adam clivens asks if there is a version
of physio's theorem for functions which
are not differentiable everywhere
uh well i mean so on the discrete cube
this
uh this this is not an issue because
every function is differentiable is q
cubed
okay um in rn you know it's the usual
thing that
that um
i mean you can extend it for free to
functions that are differentiable
in most places just because by
approximation you know once you have the
the inequality for smooth functions
you can just run an approximation on
both sides and that will give you for
if you have weak derivatives for example
right but if you want more generally
than that then i don't know you would
have to give me an analogue for the
poincare inequality and then you can
tell me uh uh
i can tell you whether it makes sense or
not okay but but it
depends i don't know exactly how to
interpret the question but but um
usually the way one proves such
inequalities in the continuous case is
you first prove it for functions that
are very smooth let's say c infinity
with compact support
and then at the end when you have the
inequality it's clear it only depends on
the
on the weak the rib you know on the weak
derivatives you can just run an
approximation both sides so that's just
considered to be a technical point it's
not a
but if you want to go beyond that then i
don't know the answer depends on what
you're looking
um yes there was another question
okay um i will move forward
by the way what you know what happens
you know what is the maximal distance
that you can approximate these things of
course is uh um
depends on what you're doing right for
example in this situation i wrote here
because there's no power p
probably you can even handle indicator
functions right because this looks like
a perimeter of what i wrote here it
would become a vector-valued parameter
but i haven't checked this
um i'm just saying this off the top of
mine okay so
um but but one usually just proves these
things by proving for smooth function
first and then at the end you can take
whatever you need
limit you need them both all right
um i have maybe about
six more minutes or so um
so what i would like to do is i would
like to uh prove pca's inequality for
you
and when you proof we says inequality
you will see um
that um the proof at least this is the
proof that's given in pca's um
in pca's notes which uh he says is a
simplification of a more complicated
proof he gave before but i've never seen
the more complicated proof
um but uh um that was shown to him by
more
i don't know this for a fact i just
that's what it's written in the notes
but let me rewrite it you will see that
this proof is extremely gaussian
so again let me write the result so the
result says
that in any norm space the expectation
of f minus the expectation of if
to the p is bounded by some constant i
wrote down what the constant is it's
like
pi over 2 to the p times the expectation
of some i is one to n
g i prime d f d x i
let's prove so
um the idea is going to be some sort of
version of the interpolation argument
i gave you last time it's very natural
to think about interpolation in order to
prove such things
so what we did last time is we started
the variance as being the expectation of
f squared minus the expectation of f
squared then we found some function that
interpolates between them
and then we were able to apply the
fundamental theorem of calculus
now the problem is when you have
something like the expected norm of a
function f
right an arbitrary norm i mean norms can
be very nasty functions you know they
don't have to be differentiable
you know there's nothing you know not
you don't want to try to differentiate
the norm because it becomes horrible
right so um it doesn't make much sense
to try to interpolate this expectation
of the norm of f to the power
but what we can do instead is we can
just try to interpolate direction
directly on the function f okay and this
is what pca does
um but pca doesn't do it with a random
construction like i wrote before
what he uses is he uses the rotational
invariance of gauss
so
we all know presumably that the gaussian
the standard gaussian distribution is
rotationally invariant
right because its density is e to the
minus euclidean norm of x
squared over 2. so if i rotate it
nothing changes right i still have the
norm the norm is rotation in there
so if i take some gaussian random
variables and i rotate it it's still a
standard gaussian variable
which means in particular right if i
take the vector
g g prime right
if i were to apply some rotation to this
vector it would still be a standard
gaussian vector
right so it has the same distribution so
let me apply rotation
so cosine so let me let me choose the
following rotation
i'm just going to rotate by an angle
theta between g and g prime right so i
have g
cosine theta plus g prime sine theta
and here let's put g prime cosine theta
minus g sine theta
right i've just i've just rotated
between g and g prime by an angle theta
and because the gaussian is rotation
invariant um
[Music]
these have the same distribution so the
the top line over here and the bottom
line over here are
both still standard gaussian vectors and
they're both still independent of each
other
right so they have the same distribution
of g and g prime
so let me call this top guy over here
let me just call it g of theta
and i'm going to call the bottom one g
prime of theta and what you should
notice is this is not just suggestive
notation
g prime really is d g d theta right
because if i differentiate the cosine i
get a minus sign and if i differentiate
the sign i get a cos
so what we're going to do is we're just
going to interpolate we take
the function f at g prime
minus the function f at g well g
prime is g at uh pi over two
and g is g at zero so this is equal to
the integral from zero to pi over two
of d d theta of f of g of theta
d theta right i'm taking two independent
gaussians
i'm writing the difference of the
function between two independent
gaussians
well i can just take a rotation which
rotates one of the gaussians to the
other and vice versa
and run our usual interpolation argument
but now we're not running the
interpolation argument at the level of
the expectation of the functions of the
norm of the function
i'm directly running the interpolation
of the functions themselves all right
so what is this well this is the
integral from 0 to pi
over 2 of sum i is 1 to n
g prime i of theta times
df dxi of
f of g sorry of g of theta
that's just the chain rule
d theta and let me just write this
suggestively
as 2 over pi times pi over 2.
this is a little bit silly of course but
i want this integral from 0 to pi over 2
to have mass 1.
right so now i've made the integral a
random right i just put a random point
on the
on between 0 and pi over 2. right so
i've just normalized the integral so it
has math
um and now that we have such an
expression if we want to take the
expectation of the norm
of these functions i can just directly
apply it here and apply jensen's
inequality right so the expectation
of the norm of f of g prime minus f of g
x to the power p well because i
normalize this integral
right i can adjust by jensen's
inequality bring the norm inside so this
is less or equal 2 over pi
times the integral from 0 to pi over 2
times
the expectation of the norm of pi over 2
sum
i is 1 to n g i prime of theta
times df dxi g of the
f of g theta to the p
but now you should remember that gi
prime of theta the pair gi prime g
doesn't depend on the distribution
doesn't depend on theta by rotational
invariance
so actually for every theta the term
inside the integral here is the same
i can just replace because i took the
expectation i can just replace g
i prime theta by g prime and g theta by
g
right by rotational invariance and then
we immediately just get the inequality
that i wrote up there that's the end of
the proof
so this is how you do the proof so this
is an interpolation proof
with two crucial differences one
difference is that we apply the
interpolation directly to the function
values we're not applying it to the
quantity we want to bound the
expectation
and the second is that we are not using
here a random construction
we're using here something very very
special to the gaussian distribution
which is rotation and variance
and of course as you can imagine the
discrete cube
is not rotation invariant you know if i
take 2 plus or minus ones and i write
cosine theta times one of them plus sine
theta times another one
obviously this is not going to have the
values plus or minus one
and you might think that this is just a
technical issue and as i'll conv i'll
try to convince you to begin the next
lecture
actually this is a fundamental point um
that uh that that has to be overcome
okay and
and uh so i'll resume uh tomorrow
thanks okay thank you so much ramon uh i
think there are a couple questions
in the in the chat if people want to
unmute themselves and ask
hi oh so in the procurement court case
where the equality is achieved by linear
functions
but here you start from some inequality
or linear functions
then derive some inequality for
nonlinear functions i'm just wondering
whether the
equality here is also achieved by linear
functions
good so let's check so i mean
here we're in the gaussian case right so
the inequality here
is that the expectation of the norm of f
minus the expectation of
f to the p is bounded by pi over 2 to
the p
times the expectation sum i is 1 to n
g i prime d f d x i
g to the p right
that's the inequality so what happens if
f of x
is some i is one to n g i
x i sorry f of g of course
then we get the expectation some i
is 1 to n g i
x i to the p
thus or equal pi over 2 to the p
of the expectation some i is one to n
g i prime and d f d x i is just g
i oh uh d f
okay i'm i make i'm confusing you a
little bit of course i wrote here d
f d x i to indicate the uh i coordinate
right of the function but of course i
plugged in the g so you should really
think of that as d f d g
i i hope it was clear in the inequality
but now that i wrote x i for some
vectors this becomes a little bit
confusing
right so what is d f d g i well just x
i it's the vector x i
so you see g i prime and g i have the
same distribution they're both standard
gaussians
right so this term and this term are the
same
so the only thing that's different is
the constant right pi over 2 to the p
is not one so this inequality doesn't
have
uh equality for linear functions with
constant one
but up to the value of the constant this
inequality is sharp for linear functions
and this is of course by
that's the whole point of this linear to
non-linear principle that this
inequality always reproduces correctly
the behavior of linear functions up to
the constant
now if you ask about the constant um you
might conjecture that this constant
should be 1 because that's what you get
for linear functions
but that's not true actually the
constant pi over 2 turns out to be sharp
and so so not just the inequality the
pca is gaussian inequality is not just
the inequality that is
sharp but it's actually the constant is
sharp
and even this constant is sharp
and this is somewhat related to
the question that was asked uh about
smoothness
um if you have uh um
if you apply this with in the scalar
case with p equals one then pci's
inequality will give you the following
very nice inequality about which i'm
going to have more to say
so what is the expectation of the
absolute value of f this is like an l
one form of the poincare inequality
right so this is bounded by the
expectation of sum
i is one to n g i prime
d f d x i of g
but you see this is now the scalar case
right so
this is just a linear combination of
gaussians it's just a gaussian
so this is like the absolute expectation
of the absolute value of a gaussian
it has constant square it's square root
2 over pi times the standard deviation
so square root 2 over pi times pi over 2
you get square root pi over 2
times the expectation of
the gradient
okay so here is a scalar inequality that
follows immediately from pca's
inequality
um and in this inequality you can take
limits and it turns out that if you take
limits it even makes sense for indicator
functions
so for indicator functions this becomes
a type of isoparametric inequality on
the left hand side you will get the l1
sorry the variance of some sort on the
right hand side you will get the surface
area of the set
and it turns out that square root pi
over 2 is exactly the sharp constant you
get it if you take a half space in the
gaussian case
um so um so this inequality does have an
equality case where the console is even
sharp and it's not linear functions
so i'm going to have a little bit more
to say about this inequality and its
analogs on the discrete cube in a later
lecture
but yeah i hope this answers the
question
but certainly for linear functions up to
the value of the constant this is sharp
yeah thank you ramon i'm going to repeat
uh two questions from clemont so
his uh one of his questions is was this
pca's original proof
i don't know it was never published
oh okay i see um he writes i if i recall
correctly he writes that it had
something to do with hermit polynomials
he expands in hermite polynomials and he
does something but i don't know what
uh what what that i don't know what it
was
i see and his second question is uh
is the case p equals infinity uh for the
norm not for the type
uh is is that hopeless if you want a
general result such as
such as the one that you just showed um
okay
um this is a good question um
you see in uh
in the gaussian inequality of course um
with p equals infinity um the result is
always true because you see
no matter what function f you choose you
have a linear combination with the gi
primes
which are gaussian so the infinity norm
of the right hand side if p is infinity
right hand side will always be infinity
so that inequality is true um
but it is not incredibly useful right um
if you're talking about pci's inequality
right if you want an l infinity norm
inequality of the df dxi's then in the
gaussian case you cannot directly get
that from pc's inequality you will have
to
um you will have to do some
approximation okay
now on the discrete cube which i haven't
told you about yet but on the discrete
cube
the situation is very different because
on the discrete cube you might hope for
an l infinity version
um and but that's a different matter and
and
if you remind me i can say more about
that next time
there are there are still a couple
questions in the chat uh the people
should be able to unmute themselves if
they want to ask
hi i have a question so the proof of pca
only uses the property of convexity of
the norm so in particular
this should be true for any convex
function so i assume you're going to
tell us about an analog for the boolean
case
but would that still be true would be
this analog still be true for all convex
functions yes
that was my answer yes you could take
any conflicts
yeah this this i just wrote the norm
because it was easier you know and uh
but yes
the norm property is not important here
at all yeah
um i can try to read can you give some
idea of how the general version of
linear to non-linear principles proof
but i don't know what you
john fengu i don't know what you mean by
the general version
i also don't know when this question was
asked
2 28.
um if you still want to ask your
question you will have to clarify what
what the question means uh
let me meanwhile go on to the other
question based on your remarks
you can prove isoperimetry in gaussian
space via pca's inequality
[Music]
um
well it's a good question
it's not certainly not the sharp
gaussianized parametric inequality now
this l one punching equality i wrote
down
right the expectation of the absolute
value of f minus the expectation of f is
bounded by the expectation of the norm
of the gradient of f
this inequality is a type of
isoparametric inequality
i can write down what it is if you apply
it to right if you take this inequality
in gauss space where you are now
okay if i plug in for f indicator
function of a set a
then the right hand side becomes i don't
remember what the constant is that you
get but you get some constant
times the surface area of the set a or
the perimeter of the set a
and on the left hand side you get
the probability of a times 1 minus the
probability of a
now this isn't this these two
inequalities are actually equivalent
okay so you can go from here to here by
plugging so from the top one to the
bottom on the plug-in indicator function
you can go the other way by using the
co-area formula okay this is a
let's not talk about that um so
and this second inequality is a type of
isoparametric inequality right it has
it says that's the probability of a set
the volume of a set is bounded by the
surface area
right so this is a type of isometric
inequality and it has a name this is
called
shiger's inequality on gauss space
so this is an analog of chiggers
inequality which which if you've ever
seen triggers inequality for
graphs or on differential manifolds
you'll know what chicago's inequality is
this inequality over here is an analog
of chiggers inequality but for gaussian
measure
but sega's inequality is not a sharp
inequality right for the gaussian
measure we have the exact sharp
gaussianized parametric inequality which
says that
the surface area of among all sets of
the same probability the surface area is
minimized by
half spaces and i have
absolutely do not believe that such an
inequality can be proved using pieces
inequality
even up to a constant so up to a
constant may be in a very roundabout way
but certainly not directly
so i hope that answers the question but
this is a type of isoprominence
it's just not the gaussian noise of
parametric
for the earlier question uh john funk
sent a clarification
i i think he was asking can you give
some idea of the general version of
can you give an idea of the proof of the
emphatic p inequality but
i think that's coming in your later
lectures yeah in the next lecture i'm
going to
you mean on the discrete cube because
the pci's inequality works in the
gaussian case right this is
we haven't done anything yet on the
discrete cube right and in the gaussian
case
um it's immediate right this is this
example the second example over here on
this page you see
if you assume that the bonus space is
gaussian type p which is just like type
e but you replace the random signs by
gaussian
then you get this gaussian form of the
inflow problem and
what you do you just take the left-hand
side of pieces inequality
just fix g condition on g and apply
the definition of gaussian type p to the
to the to the right-hand side of pieza's
inequality and it immediately gives you
this inflow type p
statement right i think this is for
calcium
yeah i think this question was asked
before you presented the proof so it's
about the
discrete case i see so the discrete case
we're going to talk about next time
i have so far not told you what is the
how you even state the the linear
non-linear principle in this
case so we're going to talk about this
in detail in the next lecture
okay uh if there are no further
questions uh
let's thank rahman again and we'll
reconvene tomorrow at nine
uh tomorrow we'll hear from erie to
ramon and jelani
okay thanks everyone see you tomorrow